it would be [ __ ] unprofessional to
not
uh
ask about the actual icp murders
the icp right there's been a bunch of
them right people identifying as
juggalos who that's
when i was on your podcast yeah i um i i
explained this and i'm not trying to
make you uncomfortable or
we were talking to violent jay on the
podcast and i was like oh man dude i
want to join the gang how do i do that
he says oh you just get a tattoo so i'm
like [ __ ] right on dude i'm gonna go
guys i was like i love tattoos i love
gangs i [ __ ] love clowns like come on
let's go right you know so so i got my
juggalo tattoo oh i've seen it so great
and and i wanted to make a big deal out
of it so i got like my crew together and
like we camped out we planned it out we
filmed this film oh yeah
yeah it was awesome we filmed the whole
thing but uh but before i got the the
ted the night before i got the tattoo i
was like oh i wonder what this means and
i like googled you know like
juggle attention and like the [ __ ]
the google feed it's just like
man
[ __ ] with the hat [ __ ] [ __ ]
attacks and you know like and then i
read an article with like one juggalo
carves a hatchet man tattoo off of his
roommate because he didn't really
deserved it and i was like thinking all
of a sudden i was like wait a second is
getting this tattoo gonna actually put
me in [ __ ] danger like am i i live
with a crazy horse
you can't speak on craig crazy people
will be crazy no matter what the [ __ ]
they're exactly you know what i'm saying
jack the ripper probably used to listen
to [ __ ] mozart did mozart catch a rap
you're saying
it's like jackass fans ended up in the
hospital like right is that is that in
the name of stevo yeah is that your
problem nah you tell them that you're
doing this [ __ ] at home
you know what i'm saying yeah what i
always said was uh it's not my fault
sorry it's not tony hawk's fault every
time a kid falls off a skateboard no
it's not you know what i'm saying hey
it's not icp's father every time someone
carves someone's skin off you know right
right okay good so we so we broached
that topic and i haven't heard that
person you're crazy person that's that
you know
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]